et bien non j'ai fait c'est si louvois
ya un an j'ai fait une vidéo dans
laquelle je traitais ma phobie qui était
la folie des araignées ces petites
créatures agréable mais qui t'est pas
tout de suite la vidéo attendait et le
hasard a fait que j'ai découvert que
j'avais une autre phobie la thalasso
phobie mais alors c'est quoi la thalasso
faux billets mais à écouter on change
pas les réflexes qu'on a acquis au lycée
la thalasso phobie du grec ancien et la
peur intense et persistante de la mer
cette phobie peu est alimenté par une
connaissance rationnelle ou à contrario
de la superstition nourrie par la
méconnaissance voire l'ignorance des
espèces constituant la faune marine
bon moi j'ai pas peur de la mer en
général mais j'ai très très peur de la
mer quand je suis assez loin de la plage
ou du banc de la cote que j'ai papier et
que je vois pas ce qu'un dans l'eau
c'est à dire que ce n'est pas de l'eau
paradisiaque transparente c'est de l'eau
de l'eau normale de l'eau de france où
tu ne vois rien du tout de ce qui
t'entoure ça me stresse énormément et ce
n'est pas que j'ai peur des requins ou
quoi au contraire j'adore ça j'ai eu la
chance d'en observer cet été en plein
snorkeling j'ai vu des petits requins de
récifs 1 pour un peu noir j'étais trop
content c'est que je trouve ça très
oppressant d'être dans un milieu où tu
es très vulnérable puisque ben on est
des merdes un boulot on est beaucoup
moins agile que sur terre et surtout
dans l'ignorance totale de ce qui
t'entoure quoi ça me stresse c'est un
peu comme les mecs dans la tente du
thread horreur la dernière fois
d'ailleurs cet été du coup j'ai pu faire
du snorkeling où j'ai vu des requins
jeunes le dire mais j'ai aussi pu un peu
plus découvrir la mer les récifs les
coraux les la faune et la flore tout ça
parce que l'eau là-bas et transparence
et après une fois je voyais de l'eau
comme ça de ma vie
donc j'étais trop content et du coup
j'avais beaucoup moins peur parce que je
voyais ce qui m'entourait et cela a
donné l'idée d'ailleurs là-bas de faire
cette vidéo là en rentrant pour traiter
définitivement m'intéresse aux phobies
surtout que ça n'arrête pas sûr
entièrement fou cette vidéo c'est du pur
mensonge
je ne la traite pas je me fais du mal
gratuitement une vidéo masochiste rien
d'autre laissez moi juste vous montrer
quelques trucs sur lesquels je suis
tombé ces derniers mois et qui m'ont
énormément intéressé dont l'un qui est
très sensée l'apparition d'un requin de
plusieurs mètres à 500 mètres de
profondeur par le directeur de recherche
sur les requins de floride c'est un
requin grise et c'est une espèce
préhistorique qui est sur terre depuis
200 millions d'années c'est incroyable
regardez regardez moi ça c'est le requin
vous voyez qui remue le sol on voit rien
et fitou noires à cette profondeur là on
voit juste parce qu'il ya des lampes
autour du sous marin
mais c'est extrêmement obscur et
regardez moi cette bête
wow quelle chance de voir ça c'est
incroyable il est énorme
regardez cet oeil ont tiré dragon on
dira personnage de dessin animé
c'est vraiment où je trouve ça vraiment
spectaculaire moi mes petits requins de
récifs de merde que j'ai vu hier et qui
sont ridicules à côté d'ailleurs sachez
une chose c'est que les requins si vous
avez la phobie des requins etc
il ya très peu d'accidents avec des
requins au final les films d'hollywood
nous ont un peu matrix et sur ça on a
très peur des requins on croit que c'est
des grands méchants qui veulent juste
buts et des humains pas du tout en vrai
la plupart du temps ils croient qu'ils
s'attaquent à une tortue ou un autre
animal il ya très peu de requins qui
attaquent volontairement des humains
pour les manger d'ailleurs pas loin des
avis c'est incroyable parce que c'est là
où il ya les créatures les plus
spectaculaires est improbable du monde
je trouve comme le baudroie abyssal qui
a une dégaine extrêmement spectaculaire
et qu'on a très peu envie de rencontrer
il ya aussi un espèce de verre énorme je
sais plus le nom qui est dans le sable
qu'il est juste dépassé sa tête et qui
choque les pressions qui passent par là
on dirait vraiment un monstre dans un
rpg que tu dois tuer pour passer le mail
4 c'est vrai prince vers la haye a aussi
une pieuvre qui est tellement mal aimé
qu'elle utilise une sorte de gros
coquillage pour se cacher dedans et
surprendre un crabe qui passent par là
pour le beauf mec c'est un autre game là
là c'est la jeune homme là nous notre
game mais là-bas en bas c'est la méga
jungle bref direction le sobre et dit le
plus compliqué pour moi le seul bris dit
qu'ils s'appellent thalasso phobie il
était un homme alors into ohlala 7
comment ce don très dur avec quelque
chose de spectaculaire qui est ce que
c'est que cette merde c'est un portail
c'est un démoniste qui est passée par là
où c'est comme un hall à la mecque c'est
flippant voici pourquoi vous ne nagez
pas dans la rivière du tennessee et ses
gros un poisson bizarre avec un animal
encore plus bizarre qui vient de le
croquer mangez-vous entre le truc
bizarre et laissez-nous en dehors de ça
s'il vous plaît
à
c'est pas drôle là ça vous amuse de
faire ça ça m'a amusé personne ici l'air
se seraient quittés au montage oh là là
voilà ça ça c'était là ça me touche en
plein coeur il saute d'un porte-avions
au milieu de l'océan
oh mon dieu voilà ça c'est typiquement
jeu je me sens pas bien c'est vraiment
le truc au milieu de l'océan quand y'a
aucune visibilité cc web on la mettait
un combo claustrophobie et thalasso fuck
est situé claustrophobe et à la thalasso
faux bitumeurs instantanément dans cet
endroit grand turk 700 foot oc andropov
ah voilà alors ça typiquement c'est je
déteste ça plus que tout c'est quand il
ya des différences de couleurs dans
l'odeur qu'on avait fait le tour des dix
millions et qu'on a fait du snorkeling
de 10 millions souvenez-vous pour ça que
le pape y avait la voix du nord elle a
coûté très cher et ben y avait ces
différences de profondeur qui se
traduisent par une différence de couleur
de l'eau là par exemple ou a clairement
qu ici c'est pas du tout profond et tu
sais il ya un trou énorme
voyez ça vraiment ça c'est terrifiant il
y avait la même chose du coup là où
j'étais cet été il ya la même chose
partout où je vais garder le merde et
c'est ça qui fait très peur quoi tu
t'aperçois vraiment que tu mets un pied
dans l'inconnu et dans un truc qui te
dépasse complètement je trouve quoi mais
qu'est ce qu'ils font c'est quoi ce
délire
oh là là mais j'ai jamais vu ça de ma
vie c'est incroyable c'est pas la
plongée bouteille sera l'apogée au
masque c'est une cloche jeta sur la tête
quoi et donc qu'est ce qui se passe ça
ne presse pas tant que ça
ouah devant cette forme est qu attend ce
serpent qui est passé à côté nous en
agent est un black band aid sucre est il
est apparemment dix fois plus venimeux
qui est un serpent de termes oies au
[ __ ] il reste à côté d'eux en plus il
est attaqué il pas s'il se dit bon
est-ce que je lâche un petit cours avant
de partir quand même c'est gratuit hop
là t'es mort en tout cas incroyable
cette manière de plonger chez mma que ça
existe et est ce que vous saviez
attention le sondage et 17% d'entre vous
savez que ça existe et c'est quand même
beaucoup je suis étonné c'est faux je
n'ai pas la stat en direct j'adorerais
l'avoir mais tout est faux regardez ces
vagues aaa
mais ils sont dans quoi c'est un bateau
c'est un sous-marin simulation c'est un
parc d'attractions quel est cet endroit
c'est possible de prendre un truc qui
est des vagues comme ça qu à un moment
tu te retrouve carrément un peu sous
l'eau je préfère pas comprendre ne me
dit pas ne me dites pas pas la réponse
at the big enough for me
[Musique]
donc le gars froid un requin je sais pas
quoi manger un requin marteau à un mètre
de lui [ __ ] un mec je suis là je peux
que rester bouche bée j'ai rien à dire à
part vite changer de vidéos parce que
c'est vraiment pas dans wait for it
j'aime pas aller wait for it make
[Musique]
la chance cet été j'ai vu des dauphins
pour la première fois de ma vie moi je
pas nager avec un gt on est pas dans un
film on était la vraie vie mais mec
c'est trop beau c'est trop majestueux et
en fait ils passent à côté du bateau et
il saute et ils font des roulades exprès
pour te faire kiffer ou peut-être pour
tenter cuir donnent à manger j'en sais
rien j'ai pas trop compris mais tout ce
que je peux vous dire c'est que c'était
incroyable ces raisons monsieur sur
instagram n'est ce pas je suis un petit
auto promo on y va on y va terrifying
olalalala tapered tombe au milieu comme
s'il y avait de la gravité alors que pas
du tout est sous l'eau très bon en tout
cas très bonne image vous pouvez
retrouver ce genre d'image sûrement à sa
g d'ailleurs c'est faux il y en a que
des comme ça
bien moins cool une seule goutte d'eau
de mer zoomez x 25 ans intéressant ça oh
la la il ya de tout ça c'est hyper
intéressant de voir à quel point il ya
différents mondes à différentes échelles
quand tu changes l'échelle il ya tout un
autre monde en fait qu'elle a ça se
trouve nous quand tu des zooms très très
fort
ça doit être incroyable ce que tu vois
peut-être je me pose des questions de
débile c'est le point d'inaccessibilité
de l'océan aka point de nemo quand tu es
à cet endroit c'est là où tu es le plus
loin de la terre aux mecs j'ai vraiment
dû imaginer pendant une demie seconde
qu'on me téléporter là-bas tout seul à
cet endroit là y'a rien à l'horizon quoi
il n'ya même pas un petit bout d'espoir
c'est horrible allons faire du
snorkeling ont-ils dit l'eau est si
claire ont-ils dit à mes arrêté me fait
terminée puisqu'après je vais avoir peur
du snorkeling alors je me suis mis à
adorer ça cet été 1 mais c'est encore
ces [ __ ] de certains fichiers pas
qu'avec ça existait ces trucs tu fuis la
terre faire pour ne pas rencontrer des
trucs banon comme des serpents il y en a
un qui fait quatre fois la taille de
ceux de la terre ferme sous l'eau et qui
est dix fois plus venimeux olalalala mot
dieu doit des panneaux l'a carrément des
panneaux la junte hervé limite ça y est
je suis allée nager dans un énorme
cratère et il se trouve que je souffre
définitivement de thalasso phobie
c'est incroyable c'est extraordinaire
pour le coup ça j'aimerais bien le faire
je me chez là dessus mais c'est
extraordinaire c'est magnifique du coup
cet été ouais parce que voilà entrés au
fait de vidéos débris des vacances entre
les moments regarde le sabre est dit
j'ai fait de la plongée pas le diplôme
ou tu payes jusqu'à 18 mètres mais là le
truc de base la découverte on va dire où
tu descends à 12 mètres j'ai adoré
c'était vraiment cool et pourtant il y
avait pas une visibilité de fougères en
voyait pas très bien du tout dans l'eau
ce jour là mais c'était vraiment
incroyable à découvrir en fait c'est fou
comme quand on a peur peur peur de
quelque chose et qu'on commence à
s'ouvrir un maître un peu le pied dedans
et ben on découvre des trucs
fantastiques et on soupçonnait pas
qu'ils aient ces trucs fantastiques là
puisqu'on avait très peur de ça avant
voilà je fais que j'extériorisé ça ce
que c'était pertinent je sais pas je
passe mes mecs mais c'est qu'elle level
de plonger le gars passe dans un endroit
tellement étroit qui doit retirer les
bouteilles de son dos et les pousser
devant lui mais c'est qu'elle levait de
plongeurs sa mecque j'ai fait ça dans
les catacombes on n'était pas dans l'eau
j'ai que j'allais mourir lui il le fait
sous l'eau ah je sais pas quel point non
mais c'est incroyable ah c'est bien ça
une petite image qui résume un petit peu
ce qu'on sait donc la profondeur maximum
où on est allé avec des bouteilles et
ses 332 mètres mais c'est le record du
monde avec un scaphandre on a pu aller
jusqu'à 700 m ce qui est très profond à
partir de laïcs y avoir des trucs
étranges le fameux calamar géant il est
autour de 2200 mètres et tout en bas
c'est le triste et ses véhicules marin
capable d'aller le plus profond dans
l'océan il peut aller jusqu'à 10 1911
m et apparemment il est déjà allé à
l'endroit le plus profond de l'océan du
coup bah oui je croyais qu'on était
jamais allé en réponse à ok vous avez vu
je maîtrise du jeu quoi j'ai essayé de
jouer simple nautique a pour dix minutes
c'est le jeu ne fut pas auquel j'ai joué
oh [ __ ] faut que je me fasse une autre
voix sur des live sur notre carte c'est
vrai qu'on y avait joué à l'époque
c'était grave
goodkap tu n'avais pas peur j'étais un
peu stressé dans ce nouveau ticket mais
ça reste un jeu donc ça va mais [ __ ]
ça va arriver
incroyable et bien les amis je suis très
content des revues cette vidéo qui est
vrai heureux mais franchement j'avais
appris plus sur sur ce milieu que
j'appréhende énormément mais de moins en
moins tout de même chez soigner ma
thalasso phobie grâce à ma chaîne
youtube et hamé viewers j'espère que ça
vous appelez moi je trouvais ça très
intéressant et encore il ya tellement de
choses que je sais pas à propos de ça et
peut-être vous vous savez j'ai continué
à me renseigner à checker plein de trucs
étonnamment écoutez je pense que je vais
passer un de ces quatre là la formation
pour replonger là franchement la vie
pleine de surprises il ya cinq ans je me
serais jamais dit why are jour j'ai
passé mon truc
manger c'est une bonne idée j'ai passé
quelque chose qui me passionne vous
savez j'adore parler quand un truc
attise la curiosité et l'intérêt j'adore
en parler youtube savez quoi je veux que
cette vidéo soit une vidéo on apprend
plein de trucs et dans la vidéo et dans
les commentaires donc tous ceux qui ont
un truc une anecdote vrai un truc à dire
une info à nous donner sur la mer les
océans et ses ébats aller dans l'espace
commentaires et est dit de nous je veux
savoir je trouve ça peut être cool dans
les espaces commentaires de vidéos comme
celle ci que pas qu'on se partage plein
d'infos plein de trucs intéressants et
que ce soit aussi cool de regarder les
commentaires que la vidéo voire même
mieux comme ça je peux je peux juste ne
pas ne plus faire j'ai pas de jets pas
la blague en fait là je vous laisse sur
cet échec je m'en vais plonger dans de
l'eau et c'est parti
[Musique]